the robot dance is the greatest novelty
dance of all time you can do it if
you're a kid or an expert and the robots
rise is the result of style and
technology playing at the same be the
robot goes back before the word robot
was invented some of the first films
show people doing mannequin dances that
have the same stilted motion with the
invention of the word robot in 1921 it
was possible to become a new type of
creature for a newly mechanical age as
robots became part of pop culture people
sought ways to interpret them but the
modern robot dance has a lot of
different parts in the late 60s a mime
named Robert Shields and later his
partner
Loretta arnelle were inspired by
mannequin dances in Shields brought his
robot on the shows like Merv Griffin's
where he dissected them within engineers
precision but the dance wouldn't exist
today without the performers who later
set it to music
some were inspired by shields and some
were completely independent inventors
Don Campbell the inventor of Campbell
locking formed a crew that included
poppers lockers and robot urns like
Charles robot Washington and Bill slim
the robot Williams who had actually
worked as a living mannequin in a
clothing store they popped locked and
robot it in recognizable dances Soul
Train gave them a platform key pioneers
like Demeter Joe Freeman robot and next
to James Brown on TV together all these
influences Soul Train lockers and the
occasional mime made what we call the
robot but it took another spark to make
the robot mainstream that spark was the
Jackson 5 the Jackson 5 performed their
hit 1973 song dancing machine on Soul
Train but that was just the beginning
there were other songs like Rufus
Thomas's funky robot but by 1974 dancing
machine was a worldwide hit with a
worldwide promotional campaign they
performed it on the Mike Douglas show
Carol Burnett a telethon date with Jerry
Lewis showed off for Johnny Carson and
even enlisted cher to do it with them
the dance assembled by street dancers
Soul Train and a few cutting-edge mimes
took over thanks to the Jacksons they
ensured it was forever known as a
dancing machine that is a robot it's all
those parts gave us the robot we know
today equally enjoyed by uncoordinated
five-year-olds uncles at weddings and
practice professionals and it succeeded
because for a mechanical dance the robot
is surprisingly flexible a big thanks to
all the robots who let us use their
footage in this video you can see more
of their dancing in their own YouTube
channels down below in the description
great way to waste a few hours but in
addition to getting footage I also
wanted to get some expertise so I asked
Adrian Bamboula aka El tiro
what this move is called and he said
that if you were pressed to find a name
for it he'd call it an arm isolation
however he'd also probably call it the
cheesy robot dance move because it's the
go-to move for non professionals